the mail must get through mail from home
nourishment for the Soul for men who are
working for peace half a world away from
their hometown an Irish soul is not
enough
we must have ships on the line and crews
demand them but more than this we must
move food and equipment to these ships
and men at their distant ocean addresses
these men need fresh vegetables and meat
on an aircraft carrier 10 tons of
groceries every day their ships need
fuel oil their aircraft need replacement
parts and their guns need ammunition
teleporter del corazon man your battle
stations
going out the first pitch guys already
spotted
today with our Navy engaged in a hot war
thousands of miles from our shores the
oil pipeline and the track for the
supply train must be stretched from new
dimensions
one temperature 83 degrees
the battle today is in Southeast Asia
tomorrow we hope there will be no battle
tomorrow the Navy's job is to take the
strength of America wherever it's needed
not always to fight thank God usually to
promote peace by making new friends and
working side-by-side with allies an
aircraft carrier task force by only
being in the North Atlantic or the
Mediterranean or the Taiwan Straits is a
kind of insurance against battle
no supermarket down the street no gas
station around the corner it's a long
way to the shopping center from here
wherever on the world's oceans our ships
must be the gas station the department
store the hardware and the grocery must
go with them for the supply fleet and
the Gulf of Tonkin this is a large order
the rendezvous address has been agreed
on an unmarked crossroads among the
waves let's come right of course 320
feet 10 knots Martha right standard
rudder by robaato ready on three 20 they
don't squeeze too too awesome all
engines ahead two-thirds
weigh-tronix my stations for transfer
keeping the task force on the job starts
at Sioux City Amarillo and San
Bernardino and at all the cities and
towns across the nation for the products
of an abundant economy are grown or
manufactured or taken from the earth
you
member
join the Navy and well Pacific Fleet
sailors do get around many seaside bases
serve as warehouses for the Fleet
Okinawa rom Subic Bay for the war in
Vietnam Subic Bay in the Philippines is
the shopping center only two days
steaming time from the Gulf of Tonkin
every time you turn around here there's
another ship from the states to be
unloaded or a ship riding high back from
Vietnam ready to be loaded out again
Yankees stationed here they come
the idea of taking supplies to ships at
sea and handing them across the water
was new to the Navy at the turn of the
century sailing ships had been able to
stay where the action was for weeks or
months sea breezes provided the power
sailors diets were less complex and
round shot was more easily stocked than
bombs and missiles then came the day of
the steamship with its huge appetite for
coal
the large men O'War burned 50 tons of
coal a day and to keep their bunkers
full had to return to port every 10 days
or so to recall the Navy learned a
lesson in 1898 during the
spanish-american war the Spanish fleet
was blockaded in the harbor at Santiago
Cuba when the Spaniards made a run for
the open sea three of our ships
including the old battleship
Massachusetts were 45 miles away being
recalled at Guantanamo the need for on
station at sea refueling was obvious
early efforts to solve the problem led
to the development of a high line for
carrying bags of coal from a Collier to
a warship one in the wake of the other
World War 1 saw the beginning of the
Navy's conversion to oil burning ships
and soon the collier's were out of
business all right when this whip which
is on ascending ship is heaved around on
it will pick the load up in the air high
enough to clear the bulwark Glenn pick
it up it took the pressure of the Second
World War on the Pacific a war that
reached into the far corners of that
ocean to make underway replenishment a
regular feature of naval operations
Americans whether ingenuity for things
mechanical worked out several ways to do
the job let's go back to this third rig
which is called a housecall ring it is
rigged much the same as the burden rig
the first rig we talked about whip is
heaped around on he brownie with me but
you lift your low clear the deck drought
hall is heave ground on which will start
your loadout board bringing across your
in hall and slacked off which will give
it low to canton area again one whip
slacked off Dillon he drowned when you
get to the other ship of the receiving
ship you'll be right over the elevator
or the other landing platform you have
both whips have to be slacked off all
right does anybody have any questions on
this rig approximately how far apart are
these ships and what would happen if
there were power casualty usually the
ship's team not more than 200 feet apart
if a power casualty happen and it's
something that will affect the rudder or
the steering of some type if the power
casualty causes a swerve on either one
ship day let's build drastic you'll
probably part all the rig's before you
can initiate emergency brake wait the
war in the Pacific made new demands on
the Navy we had the fighting ships and
men but our new mobility meant that the
supply lines had to be extended quickly
in order to project our power across
oceans and keep it there this is
Commodore Leon grabowski replenishment
group commander in the South China Sea
back in World War 2 and n Korea
combatant forces would retire from the
scene of operations to conduct their
resupply the Viet Nam operation the
supply comes two combatants labor day on
station the carrier he may be engaged in
their operation regards to what he is
doing he needs his supplies with a vp
ruler ammunition delivered right of
course the operations the hazards to the
service for ships are just as great as
they are the ocean
a spambot to receive the USS
Constellation port on the USS
Constellation 4,000 hardworking proven
asked through her child lines three
times every day
days on ref I want you people to
remember under no circumstances I want
any skylarking on this station but
anything goes wrong let me know about it
remember will be working the hedges the
same time still be swinging load keep up
between the load the bulwark and the
open hatch this is extra important keep
your feet out of the plight of the line
you got your phone line your message and
your problem make sure you keep your
feet out of any questions I mean lose we
do solution we have approximately 17
loads to send over to went to operators
you'll change the rig's during the shift
dress you men get your lines ready down
and fake all set for running anything
else all right men here she comes let's
go
for every trip from the United States
the USS Vega comes loaded with hundreds
of foods to keep those chale lines
moving 25 tons of bacon almost 2 million
eggs more than 130,000 steaks enough to
keep the constellation proof fed for
more than six months
this is automation electronic inventory
controlled by computer what makes this
control room unusual is that it operates
on a ship at sea the USS Mars the Navy
calls it a combat store ship but it's
more like a supermarket a thorough
shopper could find refrigerated food dry
foods all kinds of supplies and a
warehouse full of spare parts for almost
anything the Navy uses in this part of
the world
this is Captain H Riley Jr commanding
officer of the Mars bars handles ships
alongside both sides as do other
replenishment ships but Mars also has
the aged 46 c night helicopter and this
instrument allows Mars to replenish an
entire task group at the same time
normally the heavy will be alongside on
the portside receiving the normal
underway replenishment at the same time
these two helicopters carrying loads in
excess of one and a half to two tons
rapidly can replenish the entire screen
for instance cariot task force
destroyers not having to come off
station to come alongside at all
you're going to have Joel let us know
how much time I one for Carly well it's
not much guilt free any of really
I don't think we'll need for 30 minutes
and Mac in advance of the breakout and
children free the tree lines to go we've
got about big developed or mornin and
further for small boys we've got about
20 left I had to meet we should be
within the ballpark about the same time
or the Lord it as the worst all boys if
not early enough for white border do you
want more that's an LG fine game of
those white boys throw 900 we will have
two birds in this way it will give you a
buck ten lift very low for approximately
30 minutes
every single ver trip we all try to make
our pickup smoother and better and make
our drops but sometimes a long day of
this flying can be rather tiring because
of the concentration involved the hook
on the new age 46 is about 20 25 feet
behind the pilot seat which is a long
way back for you to be aware exactly
where that hook is at all times when you
come in over a deck for a pickup you
line up the spot in front of you and
pass over it from then on the crewmen
who is laying in the fact by the hook
looking down through the hatch directs
you right or left you also have a signal
director on the deck usually who's
giving you signs to do you tell the
crewmen going in for pickup he says
Roger I have the deck in sight and then
he says easy forward and down come in
and then he'll say easy right easy down
we have a hook up up up easy right of
easy bank mark which means the weights
come on and then loads clear you're
clear to go helicopters can pass the
bacon or the ammunition when the seas
are too rough for a High Line the Navy
is finding that it has developed its
supply techniques so well that it must
now look for ways to help ships tow the
huge amounts of surprise they receive
like the housewife who can buy almost
everything she needs at a modern
supermarket a ship on the line can make
one visit to the Mars and come away with
enough food and supplies to last three
weeks
when the tempo of operations demands
round-the-clock schedules supply ships
play a variation on their theme night
replenishment
you put a 3005 when I found load under a
helicopter you pick it up at night and
you fly out off the ship and get over
the black water between your ship and
another ship and you can't see anything
and you look at your gauges and
everything of course is pitching because
the ship swings when they were that load
under you and that the load will be
spinning or pull back and forth and you
get the weirdest sensation it's akin to
vertigo I'd say and I'd say that some of
the Harry is flying and I've ever had do
is flying at night with a heavy load
enemy that part of it is more excitement
than I care for
the Navy has come a long way since the
days of mr. Roberts and the USS
reluctant the newest trick in the
service force bag of ships is one which
will carry the beams the bullets and the
black oil here at the puget sound naval
shipyard the third ship of a new type is
readied for her launching day nearly
twice the size of her older cousins she
will carry more fuel than any oiler and
more ammunition than most ammunition
ships and groceries and clothing office
supplies and hardware too but until
there are enough of these see going
shopping centers most Navy ships will
continue to pay regular visits to the
Oilers ammunition ships and provision
ships many of these ships have been in
service since World War two the young
sung ladies of the Pacific Fleet
coconut loud rocket ship for that
variable
for want of a nail wrote then Franklin
the war was lost the job of service
group three in the western Pacific is to
make sure that the Navy's war in Vietnam
is not lost for the want of even a case
of ammunition
as the Navy adds nuclear ships to its
fleet it will slowly outgrow its thirst
for black oil but carrier Jets will
still need jet fuel and Jets have big
appetites
if automobile gasoline were being pumped
through this hose one minutes worth
would take your car from New York to San
Francisco 10 times
Navy men will never outgrow their need
for fresh vegetables and meat and mail
from home wherever in the world they
stand their duty the fleet that can
deliver anything anywhere will find them
you